toute l'équipe de
du reste on l'associé on a décidé de
nommer notre pierre à l'édifice de
suivre l'exemple que d'autres
restaurateurs avaient déjà montré et
donc aussi de faire un don de plats de
plans locaux issus de poules de
chez-nous majoritairement au chu peut
apporter notre pierre à l'édifice et
pour leur montrer notre soutien parce
que effectivement sans eux ce serait
vraiment compliqué donc c'est pour leur
montrer notre soutien pour le montrer
comme sont présents aussi bien les
parties conviendront pas si aujourd'hui
nous sommes plus aux 50 plats plus des
partis ont leur proposer de menues donc
le menu steaks de thon frais avec des
produits du pays toujours nos pêcheurs
avec du riz blanc ou sinon du colombo de
poulet avec du riz blanc toujours et les
parties s'étaient pas trop quand c'est
totalement donné c'est avec le clan
c'est avec l' envie de donner c'est avec
cécile envie de les encourager